who didn't like it besides brockman the
absolute beat down
by the buffalo bills
on
saturday night yeah there was some fits
magic in the air
because the dude didn't wear a shirt and
only came with his beard our next guest
was spending a little time with him and
we'd love to get his insight on
um said said quarterback's behavior
uh eric wood former buffalo bill first
round draft pick
for said buffalo bills here to join us
and talk to us about what this team is
doing welcome to the show eric how you
doing
i'm doing great ryan how you doing
brother it's good man it's good to have
you it's good to talk to you haven't
talked to you for a little while but
another great season by this bills team
a second consecutive afc east title and
then a third opportunity against their
hated new england patriots
and they just absolutely took him to the
woodshed what what was your impression
of this team leading up to that game
there was a ton of confidence i could
feel
uh and how did saturday night play out
yeah honestly you know throughout all my
media stuff last week i was saying i
thought the bills were
two scores better than the patriots just
when you look at the rosters when you
look at how that game played out in
foxboro when you halfway throw out the
game in orchard park because of the wind
to me the teams just weren't that close
you know you have a defense that was
down two of their cornerbacks heading
into the game some other guys dinged up
specifically dante hightower
and christian barr more on their
defensive line and the bills
got everybody back and so when you
started looking at these things a rookie
quarterback with josh allen with his
playoff experience the one x factor was
going to be bill belichick could he come
up with a game plan to slow down this
offense and give his to him a chance of
winning and that just didn't come to
fruition on saturday night
uh joining us again eric wood um what's
next
with eric wood podcast check it out
everybody where you get your podcast um
you looked at some of these games from
the weekend and you know i don't i don't
my expectations aren't as high for the
chiefs because of who they played in the
in the steelers
i do feel like the victory in the in the
way they did it because they executed so
well against
no matter what you can say about bill
belichick and what they've done
offensively he always has a game plan
defensively that's going to be
stout and get it done and this buffalo
bills team
schemed up by brian dabil
decimated them i feel like this win has
catapulted buffalo to a very high
position in the afc i don't want to make
it
too high of expectations but
this team is playing as good as anybody
right now it feels like
yeah you're exactly right i mean they're
sitting i saw this morning it's a point
and a half spread on the game so that
means on a neutral field they're saying
that the bills are a point-and-a-half
favorite if you're assuming that
arrowhead's the traditional three-point
difference in the point spread and so
yeah they're right there with the chiefs
and you know coming into the season i
think that's where everyone predicted it
would be now tennessee
you know plays more consistent ball this
year and they get into the one seed and
so now this isn't the afc championship
game this is in the divisional round but
by all
uh indications these are the two best
teams in the afc so it'll be a fun
matchup in you're right i mean the the
scheme that brian dave all put out there
i mean they used
different personnel groupings on 50
different plays they had isaiah mckenzie
had three carries in the game almost
using him in a debo samuel type role uh
the bill's you know backup slot receiver
cole beasley you know they put him in
the backfield and they they were just so
multiple offensively and then it seemed
like every time the coverage was there
and new england was in all the right
spots josh allen would make a guy's
ankles break on the outside and he reel
off another 20-yard run
josh allen uh
you brought him up he has been
um exceptional right there were times
this year where some people thought he
may have
kind of gone back in a different
direction with the three interception
game here or something like that or the
fact they were losing in games but
what they did offensively this year the
point differential i mean it was uh
record-breaking it was outrageous
they are they are playing as high a
level as they can right now
that being the case does leslie frazier
have it in him to find a way to stop
this chief's team and
and make it a game
yeah i mean so when you look at the
approaches that they've taken against
the chiefs so we'll go back to the last
three matchups so started during the
2020 season in the regular season they
played on a thursday night i believe
maybe it was it was a weekday game it
was like a covid mess with the game but
i believe it was a thursday game and so
they played in buffalo buffalo kept
their safeties high and clyde edwards
away lair rushes for over 150 yards and
the homes doesn't do a whole lot but the
chiefs get the victory then they come
playoff time the bill's brought some
pressure and you know as well as anyone
ryan when you bring pressure against
patrick mahomes you're literally that's
literally a death sentence like you may
get him once and he's going to get you
the next nine times would you bring the
blitz against them and then the bills
got beat in the afc championship game
last year so they evaluated all off
season you know the entire team is built
to play with the kansas city chiefs and
then week five of this season they kept
their safeties high they were able to
stop the run with the six-man box and
they did a lot of press on the outside a
lot more than they normally do trying to
disrupt the timing of tyree kill and
travis kelsey and then understanding
that a lot of their answers are the
screen game to the outside i believe in
their last six games including the
playoffs they throw screens on 14 of
their place
i mean that is an extremely high number
but that's how they've been able to
combat the two high safety looks that
gave them troubles earlier in the season
well
we'll see without tridevious white
buffalo's all-pro corner we'll see with
him being gone for the year without with
a torn acl if the bills can still run
those concepts and slow this chief's
offense down like they did in their
victory and airhead earlier this year
yeah that was the question i was going
to ask you know we talked about it with
mitchell schwartz just a little bit ago
i've been talking with the guys here
uh this chief's team has lost to all
three of the teams that are left in the
afc right twice early in the season
where they weren't even close and then
a
beating by joe burrow in the cincinnati
bengals late in the year that cost him
the number one overall seed does that
play any effect once the playoffs start
is it a confidence builder for the other
team or is it just something that that
happened and now
when the playoffs start you just you
throw the records out the window and you
you go to battle
yeah i think for a team like buffalo
it's pretty big because the chiefs had
had their number prior so i think
getting that win early in the season
shows them that they can win and they
can win at arrowhead now when you're
looking at the kansas city chiefs and
you're looking at the remaining afc
teams
with the amount of experience that they
have in the playoffs having represented
the afc the last two years in the super
bowl they've hosted the last three afc
championship games i think with the
amount of experience they have in the
success they've had in the playoffs it's
not as daunting on them
i i i i take it and run the fact that
you have an experience of winning an
arrowhead uh it's huge stefan diggs
and that comes from the opinion of a guy
that only played in one playoff game in
a decade so uh long career so
yeah it's worth there
same with me man one one playoff game
one one playoff round around there um so
understanding what this is like is a is
a different animal but winning an
arrowhead i played an arrowhead twice
you know once every year for my first
three years in the nfl so i know how
difficult it is to play there so when
you have that
confidence builder uh to that point
stefan diggs's picture uh that's that's
lingered throughout the year right the
the moment last year when kansas city
was celebrating that afc championship he
stayed out he watched it play out he saw
the confetti fall he saw the trophy
awarded
what did he um what did he take away
from that and did he want to see exactly
what it felt like feel that kind of that
that that stick in the guts of what what
that feels like and not not try to make
that thing ever happen again
yeah i think you're exactly right and
you know as well as anybody in moments
like that you can either embrace them
you can learn from them or you could go
try and numb yourself or kind of just
say hey the season's over let's move on
to next year your body feels terrible at
the end of the season you know you're
you're ready for this off season to get
going but you know when you're a
competitor and you are so close and you
have you know you're you're literally on
the verge of a super bowl appearance
especially for an organization that
hasn't had
tremendous success as of late like the
buffalo bills
it's just it hurts and i think he wanted
to soak it in and i think he wanted that
moment to fuel him for an entire
offseason which it has done
and
you know i feel like at times the bills
this year have been playing chess and at
times it may have affected them but it
really paid off in a big way last week
and josh allen a few weeks ago was asked
about stephon dix production being down
from last year and if that was
intentional because he wasn't 100
entering the playoffs last year even
though he was number one in the nfl and
receiving yards and catches he came in a
little dinged up and josh alluded to the
fact
that yes they've kind of
uh tempered his targets a little bit and
then emmanuel sanders was held out the
last three weeks of the season to make
sure he was
fresh for that last game against new
england and he toasts the guy for a
touchdown and so we'll see if all of the
off-season moves all of this
intentionality through the season of you
know wear and tear on guys bodies will
pay off this week
we're talking with eric wood uh buffalo
bills radio analyst and former all-pro
center
for the buffalo bills you also can catch
them on what's next
uh
with eric woods podcast there um
you made a good point there around
tempering some guys as targets
some carries some
things of that nature i've been saying
for a couple weeks now that that that
buffalo gets it right they understand
even if they wouldn't have won the east
they knew they just we to get to the
playoffs again that's that's where it
that's where it's done we know what
we're capable of just find a way to get
there
whatever what avenue we have to go to
and put us in a position and they've
gotten to that place now
if they were able to get by and win a
game this week is there an opponent in
the tennessee titans or
the cincinnati bengals that they would
rather see come up to northern new york
for that afc championship
well
i'll say this you know if tennessee wins
the bill's got to go there and going to
tennessee that's not the worst
environment to go to buffalo has always
traveled there extremely well anyways um
it's a much easier commute for me
but you know when you look at the match
and then you would get cincinnati in
buffalo cincinnati win so
looking at those you'd rather host the
playoff game now that being said
i i think the bills you know the bills
come into this game against the chiefs
as an underdog i think even if you're on
the road at tennessee next week even
having lots of them on that monday night
football game i still think the bills
come in as favorites in that game
yeah i i'd agree with you i for whatever
reason maybe it's because they've just
been out of sight out of mind i'm not
thinking about the titans right now i
just i just haven't been we got kayla
anderson not coming up in a little bit
and she's going to tell us exactly
what's going on derek henry's going to
speak to the media for the first time in
a long time
and to your into your point there i mean
to me that just points out more of what
a great coaching job mike grebel does
down there yeah you know hey we just
take care of business we play a physical
brand of ball and it may not light up
the highlight reel every week and even
if our star player who was the highlight
reel gets hurt that makes us even less
marketable and we're just going to take
care of business and get the number one
seed in um you were a guest on my
podcast he was a guest as well on the
podcast and you you peel the curtains
back on someone like him and you just
kind of get like okay your team is wired
a certain way they're successful year
after year because
most teams emulate the personality of
their head coach and down there in
tennessee they obviously emulate him
yeah they have they are tough nosed
defensive minded
rough and tumble football team you don't
want to see them you just you flat down
especially in the playoffs when it's
about defense it's about running the
football and they get the best in the
business back for the playoffs all right
the the most
wanted answer to any question what was
going on with ryan fitzpatrick last week
and how did fitzmagic uh just absolutely
uh evolve into a win in buffalo tell us
about that a little bit here at least he
has his jacket on with you there it
looks probably pregame right how did it
turn out where the beard was the only
thing left on his body i think uh by uh
by the end of the game
well funny enough that picture of us in
the booth was half half time so he just
barged in the booth at halftime
we invited him but he let me know
earlier in the week he was coming to the
game so i said hey i'll you know i'll
make sure you're in a suite you know i
got a bunch of people in town you can
sit in my foundation suite or
you know we have our legends director he
can find you some seats he said no i'm
good i already got tickets i'm like
where are you and he's like oh i'm just
in the club we're going with my son and
some of his buddies and their dads and a
couple of my old neighbors i'm like dude
you're going to get crushed he's like no
no i'll be all right
and so uh yeah by the end of the game
he's got his shirt off but i mean it
just shows
how just down to earth of a guy he truly
is the fact that he would do that and
wanted to bring his son back to buffalo
where he had so many great memories um
shoot i remember his sons from buffalo
so that was he brought tate with him
who's
12 or 13 so i mean that's 11 years yeah
i mean he was like three the last time
um i saw him in buffalo i've seen him
elsewhere but you know it's just it's
just special that he wanted to do it and
probably
he'll always go down as a favor with the
bills fans but in a podcast last year i
believe it was after asking what the
best fan base in the nfl at the time he
was the current started quarterback for
the miami dolphins and he said the
division rival buffalo bills fan base is
the best fan base he's been around so
that that got it going this weekend just
solidified his legendary status in
buffalo yeah and then you got jim kelly
and thurman thomas out there pre-game
pumping everybody up this is uh
this is a chance right since the early
90s where they went to four consecutive
super bowls and lost them all
josh allen this defense these coaches
everybody seems to have a little bit of
optimism heading into this weekend and i
think it makes for one of the best
divisional weekends in the afc side of
things that we've had in a long time
no i think you're exactly right and even
when you look at the other game and i
don't want to jeopardize your time but
i mean i would love to get your thoughts
and we could actually just hash this out
another time but i mean joe burrow from
a second year player coming off that
injury he suffered what he's doing is
remarkable to me especially when you
consider the fact he doesn't have a
whole lot of help from his offensive
line his pocket presence has been
outstanding and then just letting his
guys on the outside go make plays i mean
it's it's awesome to watch i'm assuming
you feel the same yeah i think you're
going to get a chance to see him i think
you really are i think i think the afc
championship is going to be in buffalo
and i think you can get a chance to see
him firsthand and it's going to be a
heck of a match up in a heck of a game
so eric wood thanks for joining us we
really appreciate it good luck to your
bills this weekend we'll be watching
all right i appreciate it brother all
right good to talk to you eric what
everybody former all-pro center for the
buffalo bills
absolute stud uh really got into the
transition
post career that's the name of his
podcast what's next and he really delves
into that even a guy who was an all-pro
played for
years and years and years um first first
round draft pick out of louisville
uh still felt like there was something
missing now i understand he talked about
playing in only one playoff game but
i've been around other players
you know since i've retired and been in
and out of the league
who had played 15 16 years maybe and who
won super bowl titles still feel like
they didn't accomplish
what they wanted to accomplish
right
and so
it's all about your mindset
your identity
eric does a great job with his podcast
there he's a he's pretty psyched about
this bills team i think everybody's
pretty psyched about this bill's team
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here